I agree holy [ __ ] nice repeller doesn't
that make you feel weird doesn't that
like screw up your sense of scale like
how big is the bigger one double that
dumb we're writing this World of Tanks
video and we don't know exactly what
this place looks like so it's hard to
finish and finalize a script we're doing
an actual location scout see exactly
what sort of tanks the place has and
then kind of finalize the script based
on that so let's go we're going to El
Monte yeah I think this place is pretty
cool it's great that way you managed to
also write a piece that had involves big
toys and big tanks but we don't need to
actually move them around or have them
drive anywhere it makes this concept
infinitely easier we're a 501 - see
we're nonprofit corporation and or a
certified military museum the same color
nobody but I love I love it does feel
like a little bit of a downgrade I don't
think we need to be up that far I'm
gonna take a peek inside this is
actually great innit like camera here
you can do this and it pans back that's
fun in there big old toys that's what
it's just such a big toys yeah that
one's cool yeah wow that is we're
massive you stroke and it gets longer
they go to the troop carrier or the APC
that we were walking in and out of has
like the large back so we moved to that
and then we cut to this guy here the
15-foot barrel and that's where
everything breaks down and that's it
what's wrong with this the it's not
facing outwards you're overlooking how
much of a pain in the ass it's gonna be
to film over there because of the noise
and the traffic if they do part of it
yeah 80 are you crazy
oh I would much rather make sure our
visuals and presentation is on point
there and we're about audio we got some
wireless labs and we might come up we'll
do our best and it turns out great if
not
so it starts here and like it might even
be just like the salesman is like
already here opening it and the general
like pops out best that one up [ __ ]
thank you alright
those are like oh those were from the 84
Olympics are very valuable due to
popular demand we have decided to
reprint all limited edition merch and
offer for this one time only our Black
Friday sale is still going on
checkout quarter digital calm slash
store get yourself it's sweet it's not
gonna last long is the last time we're
ever gonna sell this stuff I promise the
script in its final form now your final
it's very close why it's about four just
barely four pages long pretty good it's
tight it's pretty funny it very quickly
devolves into that it's just a character
study with the general who wants to be
all young and once like a sweet ass tank
with huge gun and then the accountant
kind of giving up giving him a reality
check that he needs to be general and
generals have troops and generals got to
support their troops I'm gonna do facial
hair and a pattern you've never seen an
invert a brand new inventive unless it
says I really want to direct this it
doesn't it doesn't really scream general
to have distracting facial hair actually
yes it does that's how you leave its the
insecure general who doesn't want to be
like you just want to have the
responsibilities of a general yeah
you're confusing me no you're confusing
me look I'm saying there's a story but
anytime you're on like a production
people question your decisions just say
it's for this story are you gonna wear
those
Sam you sure it would be tucked in
that's why I brought the combat belt
that's not proper way to roll up your
sleeve oh my god Jake every listen
you're just telling me a lot of
different things man you told me that
you wanted an American military general
oh yeah but this is more like oh this is
more like an American military general
I'm one of those guys who goes to the
jungle and then I was like wait a second
I could live like a king out here like
we got Apocalypse Now I'm like one step
away from becoming that in this piece
before before the turning point so why
cut it for the story where you have
enough I think Sam's look is the best
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Jay I want to get on the visa yep
work your ass off Minnesota they be
exciting somewhere different rocketry
mom's thank you
oh that's a long time like a month well
go for a month three months might be but
this is really mean no Jarrett you're
already questioning you're already
giving me cause for questions well you
know that's the world um is it a month
or is it two months your shoot there for
two months if it's too much I'd do two
months family to two months but not
three months three is a long time
what does that mean
lots of troops big army you know general
stuff man
general hashtag general like generals
life my favorite thing about my soldiers
is how they they do all the fighting for
me and I just get to ride around in the
tank all day they're watching this right
now yeah peace to my troops
in the civilian world you use dollies to
move refrigerators if you're moving out
of house and perhaps into an apartment
you would use a dollar to move stuff on
a film set a dolly is a specialized
piece of equipment that moves the camera
from point A to point B usually does a
pretty good job depending on the dolly
depending on the environment or location
what's a walk and talk
[Applause]
god I was gonna go with like a date with
me but it's just now that's yeah
walk and talk is usually where you got
two characters or more like an Aaron
Sorkin's show walking down a hallway or
perhaps a bunch of tanks talking through
a scene you're usually trying to shoot
it in a few shots that's usually a good
way to consolidate a lot of a lot of
content into a few shots sure it has its
place in the world it's not much camber
work I'm not a fan of bad camera work I
guess
a while back you're talking about a
stunt that happened two men brothers see
does this make it more impressive in any
way yeah it makes it terrifying you
imagine being run over with this those
of you who weren't subscribe to our
channel back then basically in Band of
Brothers have a shot where tank runs
over a dude rather than use visual
effects or camera tricks they literally
dig out a hole in the ground fill it
with like foam chunks cover it with a
light layer of dirt and the dude lies
down on it and the tank actually drives
over him and crushes him into the foam
it looks like it's pushes him into the
dirt this guy actually got ran over by a
tank crazy what the band of brothers
stunts instead of going under the tank
in the middle you have to go under the
tread but they dig out a little foam pit
instead you're gonna have to pay me a
lot more than nine hundred for that one
was like 950 like 9 grand
it's lad is zero okay would you do it
for a nightmare it feels like a bonded
and licensed set yeah yeah I imagine
they're not gonna have [ __ ] well they
put non-union for the last year yeah
exactly we have like three days yeah six
months so I don't know man but having
the actual tread go over your body and
that's some guy like what if the
cushions don't work as well as you
thought exactly
some guy said it up what if he's having
a bad day is good was that one out no no
this thing like like what if it breaks
down halfway through it's gonna crush
your head like like like crushing like a
rotten tomato the tread over your body
and how much I don't know
and they use with the red you know
because I got things like okay if I die
I'll [ __ ] how pissed is Wendy how
much does that cost priceless it's
priceless
it will be a priceless stunt 9:59 price
of the tank if I get the diff I get to
keep the tank after it rolls over me
down oh by the way it's like white all
of corridor digital today every single
member all of them got me I'll kill Carl
account little cars
punch him up oh you leave the fortress
and suddenly I'm defenseless yeah yeah
you gotta be like a special Special
Forces trooper I can I can operate
anywhere at the swamp the sky with tanks
Lily nerf man
not for nothing